what's the formula for writing a great
story I think that the a great story
starts with finding a character in a
strange situation and working that
character out of that situation and
Faulkner said that that's the way his
novel started is that a character
haunted him and he allowed it to haunt
him until he'd answered and tell
questions started coming up and he gave
the example of you know a novel I wrote
one started with a girl sitting in a
tree with muddy Underpants and her knees
were bruised and she's looking in the
window of the house from the tree and
she's crying and he said so I started
asking questions about it like why were
her knees burst well no why were he's
not first they were not versed and it's
because she climbed this tree since she
was little and didn't have any problem
climbing the tree the why were her pants
sturdy
well because her brother had pushed her
in the creek and that's why she ran home
and why was she looking in the window
because she was told not to come in the
house what was she looking at in the
window well it was the funeral of her
grandfather and so on and when he had
all those questions asked he could then
answer those questions and the thing
about longer that kind of illustrates my
view of creativity is that he didn't
write this down you know I always say
that if you trust your mind the story
will form itself in your mind the minute
you start writing it down you're
interfering with your mind because
you're now dealing with pieces of paper
and we start feeling possessive about
pieces of paper and we want to do
something with them we want to put them
in order but what if one of these piece
of paper is the good one at all well
he'll forget that he'll forget the thing
about her knees you know for example if
that's not a good one but he leaves it
all in his mind because that way it's
free to form almost like an embryo
anyway it wants to form and once it's
fully formed then you sit down and write
it out I always said people will never
have writer's block at all if they
simply never sit down to write until
they know until they know what they're
going to write when they sit down and if
you know that in advanced and you just
start dashing it out that's why you're
you limit your time forty-five minutes
an hour and at the end of it you can't
wait to write more perfect now go to
tomorrow and do it then because that
energy will be there already whereas if
you sort of run out of things to write
you've misused your time management you
know so I think that that's how a story
starts is by some character that haunts
you until you have to write about it and
then you go and apply all the other
rules about storytelling on top of that
but basically it starts with a character
and no matter how great a writer you are
if you don't have a an intriguing
character at the heart of it it doesn't
matter because you're not gonna hold
your reader you're not gonna hold your
audience the audience just wants to see
people
you